spend time with an 80 year old that is  not your grandparent just have a combo a  dinner strike up a conversation to this  day the only people I strike up  conversations with at airports are  people that I think look like Yoda like  are they 90 I want to talk to them  because they've lived it they give you  context and I'm practical then I go in  15 years I'll be 51. when you hang out  with older people you realize 51's a  child I have unlimited 50 60 and 70 year  old friends who act no different than my  30 year old friends and so a lot of you  see me publicly going deep into youth  culture I love the kids I love the  genziers the young Millennials but I  spend a lot of my not public time with  60 70 80 year olds and it's context and  that context allows me to understand